proximally a bajillion years ago when I
first reached my 1000 subscriber mark in
which I first revealed to the world that
I was actually a British born Asian guy
with a ridiculous hairdo rather than a
socially recluse pale fat white kid as
so many of you apparently imagined B ass
yeah thanks for that by the way I told
myself that I would let's make a big
thank you video when I reach 10,000
subscribers no no we're not doing that
again
partly because I guess see if you from
big insignificant round numbers that
don't actually mean anything important
but most because at the time the idea of
10,000 people continuously watching my
crappy videos was a pipe dream that
would take a lifetime and a half to
achieve fast-forward to the present then
learn behold I actually reach 10,000
subscribers and to mark this big
occasion I'm right in the middle of the
last exams I'm ever gonna take [ __ ] so
while this video may be a little rushed
and less spectacular than I originally
planned I still wanted to get something
out now rather than later so I don't get
a million messages later arty wandering
a shitty thank you video when I could
have been working on proper reviews it's
been over four years since I first
recorded edited and uploaded my bleach
review to YouTube and then attempt to
procrastinate from doing mass revision
for a level exams yes that's right the
unmei zone started because of massive
vision how [ __ ] Asian of me since
then a lot has happened to the secret
hobby of mine I got blown way out of
proportion but whatever did happen it's
you guys who kept me motivated and
coming back I read each and every
comment message posts and whatever else
that I get even if I don't reply to them
all and I can still recognize the people
who are saving me since the beginning so
whether it be ten people or ten thousand
people watching my videos I would still
be doing this regardless because I have
so much fun doing it it's just that now
I know that there are at least 10,000
stupid people in the world I don't
realize I'm just pretending to sound
smart but I actually have no idea what
I'm talking about
okay I think what I'm trying to say just
thank you thank you for sticking with me
all this time thank you for supporting
commenting liking subscribing but much
more thank you for just listening to me
you're the reason I'm here and you're
the reason I'll continue to be here and
the expensive sounded like you're boring
rubberiness and Graham dad who has way
too many stories to tell I've seen a
shape and face of the YouTube anime
community change and grow drastically
since I started and I look forward to
continued seeing it grow the only reason
I did videos in the first place was
because I've never had any real-life
friends to vent my anime geekiness on
and this place became the home for me to
do so so if there's one thing I want to
do is to help build up this community
which is still relatively small so
there's a place for people like me who
have so much to say but nowhere to say
it and no one to list
and that's about all I have to say now
sorry I couldn't make this longer or
funnier since I have very limited time
now so instead I'll just leave you all
with some bloopers that I've saved up
over my time with recording I'll have
new reviews and rants out soon but until
then I'll see you all next time
it's a rare occurrence I delve into the
world of anime Watchers follow me anime
that's currently airing because the one
who judges are finding it good anime out
of the dozens of anime coming out every
season there's probably they same
chances practical your money and the
roulette worldís eyes a lot of knife and
breathe I know you're all thinking he
got choosing up baka no character
Oh buck no buck no why don't you just
leave it buck and if you love us so much
bigger yeah this made for path Kili
expect experiment yeah experimental am I
saying again
but the biggest thing I liked about this
movie was the fact that we got to see
some bloody character development [ __ ]
you phone number 13 she's away hey would
she move from director number 13 she's
why he would you murderer
[ __ ] number 13 she's the way would she
move from driver a rapper but what a
stupid name and all I can say to that is
[ __ ] you anime anime your mum for e4 for
every fan of better than
I didn't try to judge every character by
the same criteria which can be seen here
so we have Bucky monogatari Ganesa motor
gotta birthday but you could put the but
the but then that's why I can't speak
Japanese today on the anime zone or a
view of [ __ ] okay not for the grounds a
limited list one character series just
sir is not to go [ __ ] knife the
grounds I limited the list of one
character ok I think what I'm trying to
get that is just thank you thank you for
sticking me all this time thank you for
sticking me all this time
you